avec le salon de l'auto 33e du nom paris
cette année a véritablement retrouvé les
grands jours d'avant guerre avec leur
poule et même le resquilleur
en dépit des misères du temps le salon
46 est un véritable musée de la voiture
moderne dans ses conceptions dans ces
techniques dans cette adaptation
si notre visiteur pourra voir ce
carrossier habile peut tirer d'une jeep
et partant de la voiture à tout faire
des alliés réaliser un véhicule
utilitaire aux destinations précises
l'un d'autres visiteurs parmi les
moteurs pour en faire d'utile
constatations sur les progrès de la
technique française
r il constatera que l'industrie du pneu
en france est capable de reprendre sa
place
il apprendra du centre technique de
l'automobile les leçons de l'étude
c'est en effet grâce aux expériences de
ces organisations ont été mises au point
les solutions de l'aérodynamique et de
la résistance des alliages
les expériences sur mac est réduite ne
donnant que des résultats incomplets la
plus grande soufflerie d'europe installé
à chalais mundo a été utilisé pour
procéder aux dépressions voitures rayées
des piles de leyme collé sur la
carrosserie permettent de déceler les
remous les tourbillons cependant que
leur parallélisme sous le souffle montre
la judicieuse conception de la forme
de ces décès sont nés ces carrosseries
étudier et magnifique qui sont l'orgueil
de la technique française et qui fonde
nos constructeurs dans ce domaine de la
carrosserie des lèvres sont ventilés
galets
la véritable attraction reste dans ce
temps de restriction la voiture
économique qui avec une consommation de
4 à 6 lits peut atteindre la vitesse de
90 à l'heure et pour la construction de
laquelle les divers fabricants ont fait
appel aux métaux légers
certaines de ces voitures sont notamment
construite en alliage d'aluminium ce qui
ne leur ont rien quant à la suspension
et à la tenue de route recherche de
l'économie idée de l'efficacité et les
salons nous malheureusement on ne pourra
garder généralement qu'à jolis souvenirs
dans les yeux et une vi de prospectus